a lot of excitement growing for the
expansion of area 15 but there are some
concerns increasing for nearby
businesses that are now being forced out
in particular an adult day Center that
helps those with disabilities Victoria
Saha has more on their uncertain future
[Music]
area 15's 20 acre expansion means
everything around us right now will have
to come down but during our recent
reporting we found a place tucked away
here that offers hope to those with
disabilities but now that hope may be
taken away from them and they'll have to
find another place to go my Marcus olich
loves his job I do my job do the best of
my abilities he does front desk for
Progressive choices a non-profit helping
over 140 adults with intellectual
disabilities just like him get work life
skills and training it's hard for
somebody
in our position
to look for a job it's just giving the
guys who don't have say a say in the
community but marketing director Roman
Gerard says the clock is ticking for the
non-profit to move out because Area 15
wants Universal to move in the lease
agreement you know was basically like
transitioned over to them just taking
out the entire building their property
is owned by the Fisher brothers who also
own area 15. they say they found out
about area 15's expansion in November
and was given until February to move out
with a verbal promise of ten thousand
dollars from the Fisher Brothers but
that promise seems empty as their move
out date nears from February probably
big spheres we don't have a solid
location signed it's going to be a very
difficult few weeks for us needless to
say and with funds limited it will be a
struggle to find a big enough space that
offers everything their current building
does what do you think you're gonna do
between that gap of when the facilities
are going to close and then until they
eventually find a new one
I'm gonna be stuck at home we really do
need the help now I did reach out to the
Fisher Brothers to get a status of that
promise they made to the non-profit they
responded saying in part to help ease
their transition we have pledged a
generous Financial contribution to
support their continued good work in the
community and the organization is due to
receive the pledge payment shortly but
they didn't say exactly when Victoria
Saha 8 news now Victoria thanks said the
nonprofit is putting out a request for
those who know of a location they can
move into it is also asking for
donations to help with the move if you
want to reach out or donate go to
progressivechoices.org